Welcome back everyone this will
be my video for yoda's lightsaber and how luke
skywalker got it where it came from because there
were a lot of questions after the book of boba
fett episode 6 that sort of conflict with what we
thought was pre-existing canon the story for what
happened to yoda's lightsaber just changed so i'll
explain what that is if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
john favreau and dave filoni are introducing a
whole bunch of new canon with the mandalorian
the book of boba fett series all the live-action
series that take place during this era careful for
spoilers for the book of boba fett if you have
not been watching the episodes yet but during
the book of boba fett episode 6 luke skywalker is
training grogu at his new jedi temple he intended
for grogu to become his first new student at the
jedi academy that he was creating and as a way
to test his commitment to the traditional jedi
path that luke wants him to follow he offers him
yoda's lightsaber and it's meant to be this holy
crap fanservicey type of moment to bookend an
entire episode full of yoda empire strikes back
easter eggs all of their training scenes in the
whole storyline is meant to be a parallel for
luke's jedi training and his time with yoda on
dagobah so when he whipped out yoda's lightsaber
at the end of the episode and everybody freaked
out a lot of long time fans were confused because
luke having yoda's lightsaber conflicted with
some other canonical material that claimed yoda's
lightsaber was destroyed after revenge of the sith
so what actually happened to yoda's lightsaber is
a complicated timeline issue that has a relatively
simple answer and it all starts with the way dave
filoni invoked so much yoda in the episode itself
so dave filoni wrote and directed the episode so
dave filoni is the person who chose to use yoda's
lightsaber in this story dave filoni made yoda
the character very important to the story of the
episode even though we don't actually see yoda on
screen himself he's a very important character to
episode is one of the main reasons why it's yoda's
lightsaber that he whips out at the end of the
episode instead of another special lightsaber this
super fanservicey luke had been spending all those
scenes of them training together speaking to grogu
about yoda telling him stories about training with
yoda about his funny backwards way of speaking
that made it sound like he's spoken riddles
for those of you asking if all of yoda's species
talk like that they don't yoda was the only one we
never heard yadal speak in any of the movies
of the tv shows mostly because after phantom
menace she never appeared in any of the movies
or tv shows that was because george lucas kind
of backtracked changing his mind about the way
he was using yaddle wanting to make yoda feel
more unique and if suddenly you see a bunch of
yoda's species on screen together yoda himself
starts to feel less mysterious and it takes some
of the power of the character away and if you've
never read any of the stories about george lucas
creating the yoda character yoda was sort of like
his most precious creation in all of star wars he
was always very protective of star wars but mostly
of the way they used the yoda character he didn't
want the other lucasfilm people that were writing
the expanded material to over explain yoda wanting
to keep him as mysterious as possible that's why
until grogu showed up you never saw any other of
yodo's species besides seattle for those of you
also asking what happened to yaddle there are some
non-canonical stories about what happened to her
after phantom menace but until they confirmed
she's dead in the live-action series or movies
you can assume that she's still alive out there
somewhere unless the character is confirmed dead
verbally by another character on screen in a movie
or tv show or you see a body the general rule of
thumb is that they're still alive canonically
that's why there are so many fan theories about
mace windu still being alive out there because we
never saw his body after he fell out of the window
i know you're all in my corner on this we know
jedis can fall from incredible heights and survive
so apparently i am not dead and for those of you
that want to theorize that yaddle was grogu's
mother i don't think that she was but it is a
fun theory to think that yoda was yaddling yaddle
behind the scenes of the jedi temple in the dl for
hundreds of years even though in this episode of
the book of boba fett they have this whole thing
about jedi attachments and wanting to keep grogu
from getting too attached to the mandalorian they
did make special allowances for certain jedi who
were from races in danger becoming extinct from
having children so yoda and the jedi council for
instance did allow some jedi to get married but
the story for what happened to yoda's lightsaber
before the book of boba fett episode 6 aired was
a little bit different the original canon story
was that yoda lost it on coruscant when he was
fighting emperor palpatine you can see it fall in
the senate chamber here then we see yoda falling
escape through the tubes and being rescued by bail
organa as they escape off world and we never
see the lightsaber again during revenge of the
sith they never referenced it in any of the future
materials until we got to the marvel darth vader
comic book in 2017 which was supposed to be canon
the lucasfilm story group told us it was supposed
to be canon like the story picks up right as
anakin skywalker gets his darth vader sith arbor
comes off the table starts flipping out when
palpatine is lying to him about what happened to
padme and his children and his loyalists going
around coruscant in the aftermath trying to
destroy all the remaining jedi artifacts left at
the temple and there's a scene of them collecting
a bunch of jedi lightsabers and throwing them into
an incinerator mas amedda himself holds up what
appears to be yoda's lightsaber and toss it into
the pile as they light it up the kyber crystals
all exploding while this is happening palpatine is
instructing darth vader and how to create his new
red sith lightsaber that we see in the movies
saying that he has to take a regular kyber
crystal from a jedi and corrupt it you can't just
go out and find a red kyber crystal sith crystals
have to be taken not given or found and as he's
giving them all these instructions and they're
watching these lightsabers be incinerated he
mentions yoda's lightsaber as mas amedda is
throwing the one that looks like yoda's on the
pile so they want you to think that palpatine's
forces had found yoda's lightsaber in the
senate chamber after their fight and they
were destroying it now so it's heavily implied
they destroyed it but never outright confirmed
that's why after seeing this fans just assumed
yoda's lightsaber was destroyed and that's why
we never saw it again after revenge of the sith
in any of the star wars rebels episodes the bad
batch episodes or any of the new movies later
in the timeline so that's why a lot of longtime
fans were so surprised when luke whipped it out
at the end of the book of boba fett episode 6
looking nonetheless for wear like where did this
come from how did he get it it's not meant to be
a copy this is meant to be yoda's original
lightsaber he never had multiple lightsabers
so now this brand new story for yoda's lightsaber
in the episode supersedes the comic book story the
way it works in the star wars universe is that
the live-action stuff the movies the live-action
tv shows are always meant to be the most official
canon amongst all things that are canon there's
like a tear list it always starts with the live
action stuff this happened when the prequel movies
came out too there was a bunch of pre-existing
story that they developed in the expanded universe
about the history of the jedi and what happened
to certain side characters or characters from
antiquity that the prequels kind of trampled on
but because it's george lucas making new movies
the new movies were the official canon so if
there's anything in a new tv show new movie that
contradicts something from a book or like a comic
book the new live-action stuff is the official can
it just replaces what the pre-existing story was
right now dave filoni john favreau are kind of
like the top-tier stewards of the star wars canon
during this era the mandalorian takes place during
so their story is the new official canon dave
filoni like i said wrote and directed this episode
so he's the person that wanted luke skywalker to
whip out yoda's lightsaber and there's actually
one of the complete location books published
by lucasfilm after force awakens came out that
helps fill in some of the gaps with what happened
to yoda's lightsaber after revenge of the sith
the new official canon story until something else
comes out in the future along to retconnet again
is that yoda lost his lightsaber fighting emperor
palpatine like we all saw in revenge of the sith
then off screen while he was in the process of
escaping he recovered the lightsaber took it
with him when he went to dagobah and just kept
it in this wooden box in his hut so the wooden
box that's sitting here next to luke skywalker
where he got the lightsaber from that was the
box that yoda kept it in and yoda just chose
to never use it again while he was on dagobah
mostly because he didn't need it then after he
died and became a force ghost luke skywalker
faced darth vader and together they seemingly
killed emperor palpatine even though darth vader
was the one that threw him down the shaft after
all the dust the battle of endor settles luke
skywalker begins the process of reviving the jedi
order creating his new jedi temple the academy
at some point he went back to dagobah to collect
all the jedi artifacts that yoda had kept in his
hud and that's when he got this box with yoda's
lightsaber in it during that part of the timeline
between return of the jedi and the mandalorian
season 2 episode 8 luke had been traveling all
over the galaxy looking for jedi artifacts and
force sensitive students to train that's one of
the reasons why it was luke skywalker to show up
in the mandalorian season 2 finale to help them
he felt grogu's beacon in the force because he'd
very specifically been listening for beacons
like that but they've never referenced yoda's
lightsaber in any of the new movies so anything
that dave filoni and john favreau do with yoda's
lightsaber and present day of the mandalorian and
boba fett episodes is totally new canon luke is
making grogu choose between it and the mandalorian
armor and even though they've clearly foreshadowed
grogu will return to the mandalorian and that
would mean that he'd have to choose the armor
over yoda's lightsaber purr luke's instructions
here yes it is possible that there's a twist and
luke still lets grogu take the lightsaber with him
i'd really like to see him construct a
totally different lightsaber eventually
but talk about more easter eggs for the classic
trilogy luke skywalker used his father anakin
skywalker's original blue lightsaber for a long
time before he created his own green lightsaber so
it's always possible the grogu gets to use yoda's
green lightsaber for a while before he eventually
creates his own totally different one he's gonna
live for like 900 plus years so he's got plenty
of time to make his own new lightsaber they also
probably want to sell a bunch of toys with grogu
wielding yoda's lightsaber just you wait there
will be a toy for this that you can buy let me
know in the comments though if grogu leaves luke
skywalker in the jedi academy do you think that
luke will still let him have yoda's lightsaber
my full book of boba fett episode 7 finale video
will post next week just like normal then i'll
start doing some more mandalorian season 3 videos
everyone click here for that new luke skywalker
grogu video and click here for my full book of
boba fett episode 6 video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and this is the way!